what's up elimination is as in my one
word is believe and I believe in people
more than they believe in themselves and
my sincere hope is that if you see in
yourself what I see in you you'll be
able to go up and change the planet now
we started a mentor me series to try to
learn from people who've done a lot more
than us and by hanging around them and
absorbing their wisdom and their
knowledge some of their mindsets their
beliefs their attitudes their way of
seeing the world seep into us to help us
become the best version of ourselves so
today we're going to learn from simon
Sinek and how to start with why mentor
me Simon
[Music]
the Y was born out of pain it was never
an academic or commercial exercise it
was born out of a time in my life many
years ago ten years ago where I had lost
my passion for what I was doing I owned
my own small business I was living the
American dream
superficially my life was fantastic and
yet I didn't want to wake up and do it
again and I was embarrassed by that you
know who might have complained about my
life my life seemed perfect and yet I
hated it and so I kept it to myself
every ounce of my being every all the
energy that I had was invested in
pretending that I was happier more
successful and more in control than I
felt and it was debilitating quite
frankly strange things start to happen
when you put yourself in that cycle and
the stress starts to build you start to
become paranoid so for example I was
convinced that my employees hated me I
didn't go out much and it was really
really a bad time there was a confluence
of events and I made this discovery that
every single organization on the planet
even our own career is always function
on the same three levels what we do how
we do it and why we do it and it was
based on the biology of human
decision-making it wasn't some
highfalutin management theory it's based
on brain stuff and I realized I knew
what I did it was but--at it and I knew
how I did it I could tell you what was
different or special about the way I did
things but I couldn't tell you why I was
doing it that was the missing piece you
have to have all three I became obsessed
with this thing called the wine I
figured out how to find my wine and it
restored my passion to levels I had
never experienced before and more
importantly I figured out how to help
others find theirs and I did what anyone
would do when you discover something
beautiful you share it with your friends
and my friend started making crazy life
changes themselves and they started
finding happiness and passion that
they'd never experienced before it was
me solving my own problem that happened
to help others solve it for them too and
people just kept inviting me and I just
kept saying yes
I was making huge decisions that were
really easy to make
like I shut down my office and started
over again because I realized that
business I had built was so inconsistent
with my wife all my friends thought I
went out of business they were worried
about me he was the easiest decision I
ever made in other words when you know
your why the filter is clear it's not
like there are options the option is
obvious there's only one option chair
gives inspired as it turns out there's a
pattern as it turns out all the great
and inspiring leaders and organizations
in the world whether it's apple or
Martin Luther King or the Wright
brothers they all think act and
communicate the exact same way and it's
the complete opposite to everyone else
all I did was codify it and it's
probably the world's simplest idea I
call it the Golden Circle
[Music]
why how what this little idea explains
why some organizations and some leaders
are able to inspire where others aren't
let me define the terms really quickly
every single person every single
organization on the planet knows what
they do 100 percent some know how they
do it whether you call it your
differentiating value proposition or
your proprietary process or your USP but
very very few people or organizations
know why they do what they do and by why
I don't mean to make a profit that's a
result it's always a result by why I
mean what's your purpose what's your
cause what's your belief why does your
organization exist why do you get out of
bed in the morning and why should anyone
care well as a result the way we think
the way we act the way we communicate is
from the outside in it's obvious we go
from the clearest thing to the fuzziest
thing but the inspired leaders in the
inspire or inspired organizations
regardless of their size regardless of
their industry all think act and
communicate from the inside out you know
sometimes you can give somebody all the
facts and figures and I know what all
the facts and details say but it just
doesn't feel right why would we use that
verb it doesn't feel right because the
part of the brain that controls
decision-making doesn't control language
and the best we can muster up is I don't
know it just doesn't feel right or
sometimes you say you're leading with
your heart or you're leading with your
soul well I hate to break it to you
there's onde other body parts
controlling your behavior it's all
happening here in your limbic brain the
part of the brain that controls
decision-making and not language but if
you don't know why you do what you do
and people respond to why you do what
you do then how will anybody how will
you ever get people to vote for your by
something from you or more importantly
be loyal and want to be a part of what
it is what you that you do again the
goal is not just as to sell people to
need what you have the goal is to sell
to people who believe what you believe
the goal is not just to hire people who
need a job
it's to hire people who believe what you
believe I always say that you know this
if you if you if um
hire people just because they can do a
job they'll work for your money but if
you hire people who believe what you
believe they work for you with blood and
sweat and tears and no era but nowhere
else is there a better example of this
than with the Wright brothers most
people don't know about Samuel Pierpont
Langley and back in the early 20th
century the pursuit of powered man
flight was like the dot-com of the day
everybody was trying it and Samuel
Pierpont Langley had what we assume to
be the recipe for success I mean even
now you ask people why did your product
or why did your company fail and people
always give you the permit same
permutation of the same three things
undercapitalized the wrong people bad
market conditions it's always the same
three things so let's explore that
Samuel Pierpont Langley was given
$50,000 by the War Department to figure
out this flying machine money was no
problem he held a seat at harvard and
worked at the Smithsonian and was
extremely well-connected he knew all the
big minds of the day he hired the best
minds money could find and the market
conditions were fantastic the New York
Times followed him around everywhere and
everyone was rooting for Langley and how
can we've never heard of Samuel Pierpont
Langley a few hundred miles away in
Dayton Ohio Orville and Wilbur Wright
they had none of what we consider to be
the recipe for success they had no money
they paid for their dream with the
proceeds from their bicycle shop not a
single person on the Wright brothers
team had a college education
not even Orville or Wilbur and the New
York Times followed them around nowhere
the difference was Orville and Wilbur
were driven by a caused by a purpose by
a belief they believed that if they
could figure out this flying machine
it'll change the course of the world
[Music]
Samuel Pierpont Langley was different he
wanted to be rich and he want to be
famous he was in pursuit of the result
he was in pursuit of the riches and lo
and behold look what happened the people
who believed in the Wright brothers
dream worked with them with blood and
sweat and tears the others just worked
for the paycheck and they tell stories
of how every time the Wright brothers
went out they would have to take five
sets of parts because that's how many
times they would
crash before they came in for supper and
eventually on December 17th 1903 the
Wright brothers took flight and no one
was there to even experience it we found
out about it a few days later and
further proof that Langley was motivated
by the wrong thing the day the Wright
brothers took flight he quit he could
have said that's an amazing discovery
guys and I will improve upon your
technology but he didn't he wasn't first
he didn't get rich he didn't get famous
so he quit people don't buy what you do
they buy why you do it and if you talk
about what you believe you will attract
those who believe what you believe
people often say that they think they
have their wire well more than that that
they feel it that it feels right and
they know they're in the ballpark but
they're struggling to find the words
that's okay the most important part
about this why process is that indeed it
feels right remember the why exists in
the part of the brain the limbic brain
that control their feelings it also
controls all our behavior and
decision-making and so we don't want to
think that it's right we want to feel
that it's right and once you have that
gut decision that that's it and you get
goosebumps when you start telling the
stories that you think push you in
towards your why then you know you have
it if you start to well up or have an
emotional response you definitely know
you're in the ballpark then the trick is
to find the words and it's the word it's
the ability to articulate your why that
makes it actionable and so absolutely
the why the the words will evolve the
words will adapt to change but the
meaning cannot it's the meaning of those
words those words that give you that
visceral feeling those greet them but
make you well whatever the feeling you
have is that's what's paramount but the
words you can tweak and change
absolutely for the end of time I've
tweaked my wife multiple times over the
years but the meaning of it in the basic
direction is still exactly the same it's
like a submarine when the captain orders
a submarine to go north the submarine
doesn't go in a straight line it kind of
goes like this and you're why is the
same thing you need to know that
it's heading but it's okay if it goes
like this as you're tweaking the words
as long as you're moving in the right
direction
learning to start with y really is
especially in a business context when
you're interviewing for a job or
pitching your services to someone it
really is remarkable I get so many
letters from people you know all excited
that they went into a pitch or they went
into a job interview and they started
with Y and they were so excited that not
only did they get the job but the person
who hired them actually said we love dot
dot dot and they repeat their why back
them they don't talk about their
qualifications or any of these things in
other words it really does Drive human
behavior and the more you get good at it
the more you start to feel and see the
results of starting with what what
you'll find is that that the better you
are at communicating your why people
will want to work for you regardless of
the opportunity that you afford them
like they want to be a part of it yes we
do a little thing which we've been doing
for years and years and years called
give and take whenever there's any kind
of relationship whether it's a an
outside partnership or even somebody who
joins our team we do something called a
give-and-take where we want somebody to
be selfish and selfless within the
relationship so not given get a give and
take so we'll ask them what is it that
you have to give to us that you have
that you think that we need right and
they'll tell us and then we'll say great
what is it that you selfishly want from
us
and we want them to tell us what they
can get the muscle that's home and when
those when those things match you have a
balanced relationship because so example
I've had it with people will you know
they'll tell me what they what they have
to offer and that's awesome because
that's what I want and then they'll say
what they have what they want to take
and they go oh I want to work with the
smart people I'm like plenty of smart
people what is it you want to take from
me they're like I want to help build
something wonderful do that anywhere
where you want to take selfishly from me
they can get into words and if they
can't answer the question I won't engage
in a relationship and the reason is
because in time the relationship is
unbalanced they're going to be giving
but they're not taking and I don't even
know how to give them what they want
then they'll complain that I'm making it
up lennier because it's not balanced
that's right now it's time to put your
why into action
discovering your why it's just the
beginning in order to enjoy all the
benefits of having a clearly articulated
why you'll need to have the car
and discipline to use it like Thomas
Edison said vision without execution is
hallucination there is an ideal order of
implementing your why though sometimes
reality does get in the way and it all
starts with you our natural tendency is
to start with the tangible we define our
value by what we do so it takes practice
to start with why like riding a bicycle
at first we're unsure unsteady we're in
our head thinking about all the things
we need to do pedal fast keep enough
speed so we don't fall over we have to
really concentrate we may even fall over
you can scrape our knees but we get back
on the bike and try again and eventually
it becomes natural
starting with why is no different at
first it feels awkward it may not even
work but with practice it will become so
natural that you won't even be able to
imagine a time when you couldn't do it
just like riding a bicycle in time
you're why will act as a filter for many
of the decisions and choices you make it
becomes a tool to help you find a job or
seize an opportunity in which you're
more likely to succeed it removes a lot
of the guessing here's a metaphor to
show you what I mean it's called the
celery test we're constantly asking
people for their advice on what to do or
how to do it it's like going to a dinner
party and somebody says do you know what
you need you need M&Ms we've done so
well with M&Ms you've got to use M&Ms
somebody else says to us rice milk in
this economy you have to use rice milk
someone else says to us Kit Kats you
have to use Kit Kats and somebody else
says to you it's all about celery we go
to the supermarket with all this good
advice from all these smart people with
brilliant case studies and we buy
everything we buy Kit Kats and M&Ms
celery and rice milk there's a lot of
time we spend at the supermarket and a
lot of money we spend at the supermarket
and when we get to the checkout line
we're standing there with all these
products in our hands and no one can see
what we believe because we bought
everything but let's imagine we know our
why let's imagine our wise to always be
healthy and only do things that protect
the health of our bodies
now which products do we buy given all
the same advice
from all the same smart people this time
we only buy celery and we only buy rice
milk they're the only two that makes
sense we spend less time and less money
at the supermarket and when we're
standing there in line with only celery
and only rice milk now people can see
what we believe somebody walking past
can say hey I can see that you're
healthy so am I
you just attracted an opportunity or a
referral or a friend simply by saying
and doing the thing that you believe and
the best part is it scalable as soon as
I said the Y you knew exactly which
products we were going to buy this means
the more you can articulate your why the
more others will know what you stand for
and will be able to help you make the
right decisions from now on you will
work to ensure everything you do is a
good fit if you do too many things that
aren't a good fit
you will feel uncomfortable and people
will feel that you're being inauthentic
on the other hand when you start with Y
your ability to stand out find support
and work to all your natural strengths
will flourish with practice you will
learn to trust your Y you will
eventually start to see your job and the
things you do as ways to breathe life
into your cause and the better you get
at it the more you will feel that your
life and everything you do has purpose
the best way to implement your Y is to
work at it slowly you don't have to do
all the tips we suggest what is
important is that you pick up 2 3 and
commit to practicing and using them now
thank you guys so much for watching I'd
love to know what did you think what did
you take from this video from sign way
that you're going to immediately apply
somehow to your life or to your business
please leave it down the comments below
I'm really kind of see what you guys
have to say thank you guys again for
watching I believe in you hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever you're one where it is much
love I'll see you soon
[Music]